you've read about this a lot there's
essentially one trunk of the internet
going in the North Korean thats dark
right now that's right north korea has
very very few connections to the
internet in fact they only have four
official networks connecting the country
to the internet and you can compare that
with over a hundred and fifty two
thousand for the u.s. so when all of
this tension started erupting with North
Korea it's very likely that the United
States or maybe some patriotic hackers
took a look at those at those networks
and said there are only four of them we
might like to take those out and today
they did yeah I guess you're saying that
Seth Rogen didn't do it himself you know
I wonder if this is the kind of
proportional response that the president
might be talking about or this is a more
permanent thing where they if they're
going to abuse the internet that the
United States is decided to take that
power away from them completely it's
basically saying you know you're not
playing well with others and we're going
to kick you off the internet and that's
that's a real disadvantage for North
Korea you know basically having so few
outbound connections to the Internet
however we talked to one security expert
this morning who pointed out they said
look North Korea's Internet
infrastructure is not interwoven into
the fabric of their their daily lives or
even the government's operations and you
know North Korea launches many of its
cyber warfare attacks from outside the
country they have too much they have so
little bandwidth so dispersed or a
couple weeks ago to that effect sort of
saying that it was in the UAE was in
Germany was in China all over the world
yeah and it so this the the person we
talked to this morning is said you know
this may be nothing more than symbolic
but as a proportional response it's
pretty much in line with you know this
doesn't really harm citizens citizens
there don't have access to the Internet
this harms the government it's kind of a
black eye for the North Korean
government and it's very low impact in
terms of impact on the common individual
there so you could potentially see the
u.s. launching this or potentially some
some patriotic hackers as well